who is trump in all of this right now i
know you've spoken about trump comparing
him to cyrus the great you've spoken
about
trump comparing him to uh uh king uh uh
i want to pronounce it right
jihu uh uh yeah so you you
who is trump uh what role is he playing
in all of this
okay yeah to america now this is and
just and we we were speaking just before
the show
this is in this is in uh another book i
did called the paradigm i mean i mean
it's related to the harbinger too
but it's the paradigm the paradigm is
showing that it's not only the signs
that are replaying but the
people are replaying that meaning
that behind the leaders of israel are
behind the leaders of our time
there are they're following the
prototype of ancient leaders so it's not
just
it's not just the signs it's the people
our son and trump is one of them
what happens is we won't be able to go
through
all that but but you can get the the the
paradigm anywhere and
we can talk at any time but every leader
from clinton
you know bill clinton to hillary clinton
to barack obama
to trump all the every single one
follows it like clockwork and not just
the people
but the time that they're going to be on
the national stage exactly
so what i'll just i'll put it this way
from the paradigm
there's a moment when when israel is
about is really ready to
to seal its fall away from god and what
you have in power
you have you have behind the scenes is a
woman named jezebel
jezebel is is is part of the house
her she was the wife of the king ahab
but now he's not king anymore but she's
still
behind the scenes of power well this is
not about a person we gotta pray for all
people love all people but
this is gonna match hillary clinton and
and
and i'm not saying that because i have
anything about hillary clinton there are
people who say this because they do
but the fact is she's gonna follow this
exactly um and
and she is there and what it comes down
to is the nation's about to
is that a crossroad and and it's either
gonna follow the house of
hillary clinton or spouse of jezebel or
or something's gonna happen
so what happens is at that moment when
it looks like jezebel
and her house is gonna rain forever uh
god raises up a man called jehu jehu is
a warrior
he's a fighter he's not a politician
well donald trump is not a
is a fighter uh jehu is impulsive he
just you can't predict him he does this
does that
so is donald trump uh jehu
jehu begins a race to the throne
and he gets on his chariot begins a race
now now now donald trump began a race to
the presidency a guy in the bible is
watching jay who comes watching the
charity
who is it says well i don't know but
it's he drives like jehu because he
drives kind of like like like he's crazy
well
the race of donald trump to the white
house was crazy but the thing is that
what happens is
jehu then it comes down to a com a
confrontation between jehu
the warrior and and the and jezebel the
former first lady
and so you have in america the warrior
trump
jehu and you have the former first lady
of america
hillary clinton and when you and the one
and everybody said you know
hillary's clinton's gonna win it's gonna
wipe out but the bible said that when
they come together
hillary oh j the jezebel's going to fall
and jehu is going to rise to power and
that's exactly what happened
and i'll there's so much but let me tell
you this about this
jezebel was in was on the national stage
for 22 years 22 years
with her husband ahab
and on her own after her husband's reign
was over 14 years
well jezebel well that's just about
hillary clinton
was on the national stage from the
moment that her husband became governor
of arkansas
to the end of his presidency how many
years was it 22 years
how many years was she on her own she
she retired for public life for two
years came back
altogether 14 years exactly
as at exactly exactly
so you've got donald trump then but the
importance of donald trump it's not
about trump doesn't matter what you
think about him
because jehu was was wild but god raised
up
uh jehu at to to give the nation
a little bit more time to hold back you
know what
actually we can see it happen to hold
back this this wave that was going to
seal the nation's fall and end
and begin persecution and end the gospel
he hold back so donald trump
gave up reprieve it's not about donald
trump not saying he's not reading this
okay
but but he he's doing that so and this
matches up with what we just said in the
harbinger too
this is part of the window of time well
donald trump was an extension of that
but now we're coming to a crucial moment
that's why all these things are coming
to a head
all these things and the virus and the
economic collapse and the lockdown and
the
the the unrest is all part of the
biblical mystery
began in the harbinger from the bible
and is resuming now and that's why i
knew
i had to write the harbinger too because
we're we're in it right now